みなさん、ここでダガンです。手が少し良くなっている
ので、現在、日本のスタイルのビデオで新しい通常のビデオに取り組んでい
ますが、
それでも
通常よりも少し時間がかかるので、このビデオで何をしていますか
前回の投稿でお話ししたようなオフィスツアーな
ので、このビデオから始めましょう。
私が撮影した部屋のツアー
をお見せします。それから、
アルフレッドやキーボードマエストロなど、ソフトウェアを使ってやっていることは
たくさんある
ので、後で説明します。
最初にやりたいことは、日本語を言う
ときの通常のテイクをいくつか行うことです。
後で編集モードに入るときに使用する
ので、ここにいくつか連れ
て行って、私を家に呼んでもらえるかもしれません。
地元の9マス
そして多分私達はもう1つの異なる種類をするでしょう
これであなたの犬が必要になります
これで誰かがあなたの犬を食べることを知ってい
ますあなたは誰かがこれであなたの犬を食べることを知っています
iPhoneのカメラにシフトして、撮影時に
どのように見えるかを正確に確認できるようにします。
今すぐそれを実行しましょ
う。最近、 私の携帯電話のカメラには少し問題があります
が、うまくいけば
大丈夫です。
カメラの反対側にいる
私たちの仕事の哲学の主なものの1つは、私
が非常にこだわりを持っていることです。 美学と
美学は明らかに完全に主観的です
が、私は
アップル製品の見た目と感触が本当に好きです。それが
私がMacBookを使用する理由であり、それが
私がこの特定のデスクを手に入れ
た理由であり、 第二
に、しかし私にとって、コンピュータのパフォーマンスは
ほとんどインポではありません 環境を作成するのと同じよう
に、創造性を発揮できる作業環境を作成する
ことで、自分のクリエイティブなジュース
を今すぐ流すことができます。MacBookProを使用して
、青いYeti
マイクを直接接続するだけです。 私の
カードは今実際に取り付けられて
います。これについては少し後で説明しますが
、BlackmagicCinemaポケットカメラを使用している
カメラBlackmagicPocket Cinema
Cameraはオリジナルのものであり
、実際には意図していない4kカメラではありません。
4kにアップグレードするのは、
これが非常に多くのテクスチャーを出すというイメージが好きだったからです。フィルムのような質感が、
効果を適用せずに通常どおりに出すような粒子に
見え
ます。 スピードブースターと
、前面にFD可変フィルターを備えたsigma 35 30 mm 1.4アートレンズ。
これで、素敵なボケを手に入れることができます。
これらすべてを使用し、初日から使用しています。
upgrを計画していません 私は4kは私が個人的に必要だと思うものではないので、
それが壊れない限り、そしてこれがすべて壊れた
としても、新しいものではなく、これらの古いものの別のものを手に入れます。
ここのマンフロット三脚に
あり、これはクローズアップのジャックライトなので
、照明に関しては
少し複雑ですが、ここに立って
いるライトが
あります。これだけがオンになっていると、顔に厳しい影ができます。
だから、目の前から光が必要で、そのように
角度
をつけて机の上に置くことができるリフレクターを持っていましたが、
この部屋はとても小さいので
、リフレクターを置くたびに
取り上げます 部屋の半分と私は
それをそこに置いて、すべてのショットごとにそれを
取り除く必要があるので、それは
ちょっと大きな苦痛でした、そして私は物事を単純化
して合理化したいので、私は
非常に小さいこのフラップジャックライトを手に入れ
ました フットプリントが非常に小さく
、光が出てくるのでdiffu
すでにsedは、
追加のソフトボックスなどは
必要ありません。見栄えが良いので、これは
基本的
に私の後ろの壁を照らします。これは私の顔の大部分を照らし
ます。実際、ここのコンピューター
は古いものになります。 撮影時に
説明のためにここにあるスクリプト
は、コンピューターの明るさを完全に
上げています。この白い背景のため、残りの光を埋めるのに十分な光
がここから出てきます。
私の顔
の左側はあなたの男の観点からは右側
ですが
、それは私のオフィスのことについてあまり冗長になりたくないです
ええこれは
私が手に入れた新しいキーボードですそれは彼らの
エコードクの足と呼ばれています 半分なので、これは
本当にコーンオムニコンIIであり、
ここにはこれらの素晴らしい親指クラスター
があり、指よりも親指の方が多くの作業を行うことができます。これ
は、指の痛みが多いのです
が、あまり多くないので良いことです。
サムパン次に、このレインスタンドにコンピューターを置いたところ、
これは少し面白いかもしれませんが、
最初から3分の1のルールを適用しようとしたので、これに取り組んでいます。
3番目の
本棚はこの3番目にあり、2つの
本棚も実際には
フレームを水平方向に3分の1に分割し
ます。これにより
、ショットまたはすべてのショットの一般的な構成が適切に作成される
ため、私のビデオは
非常にシンプルに見えますが、
基本的にハードウェア側のすべてであると設定することに多くの考慮が払われた
ので、
今私たちができることは
ソフトウェア側に飛び込むことです。ソフトウェアは私
がこの特定のビデオのために本当に集中したいものです。
ここで提供する情報が
特定の視聴者に役立つことを願っています。確かに、この情報の一部は、
コンピューターの使用方法を根本的に
変えてくれました。
この
特定のビデオに集中するのは2つのプログラムです。1つは
アルフレッドで、もう1つは
私が本当に集中するの
はこのプログラムのキーボードマエストロ
です。このソフトウェアの同様のバージョンがWindowsIにあると思います。
それはオートホットキーと呼ばれていると信じてい
ますが、とにかく始めましょう。
今すぐSDカードを
接続しました。これを開くと
、SDカード上の唯一のファイルが
からのビデオであることがわかります。 カメラとAlfredを開くと、
Alfredは基本
的にスポットライトのようなツールであるため
、コンピューター内のファイルをすばやく検索できますが
、詳細については後で少し説明し
ます。 オーディオハイジャックフォルダを開くと、
これが
青いイエティマイクからのオーディオ
が録音されるもう1つのフォルダになるので
、BlackmagicカメラのビデオをSDカードに録画し、
現在
コンピュータに接続されているこの車に入れてから、
オーディオはこのフォルダに送られますオーディオ
ハイジャックされたので、これらは現在2つの別々の
フォルダにあります。これは
、Final Cut Proプロジェクトを開くときに、
別のフォルダをナビゲートしてインポートする必要があるため、私にとっては一種の苦痛です。
編集を開始する前に各プロジェクトに必要なメディアな
ので、今すぐ何かを試して、
何が起こるかを確認し
ます。SDカードコマンドを取り出し
ます。プラグを差し直して、何が起こるかを確認します。
だから私はそれを抜いて、今
私はそれを再び差し込んでいるので、
何が起こるか見てみましょう
私は私のコンピュータの何にも触れない
のでそれが現れましたそして今私たちはそれがすぐに消えるフォルダを見ることができ
ます
がオーディオファイル オーディオファイル
はフォルダ内にあるので、
なぜこれが起こったのですか？これは、
キーボードマエストロこのソフトウェアを使用して
、
そのファイルをSDカードに自動的に移動し、
オーディオという名前のファイルを検索するワークフローを設定したためです。
iffそしてそれはそれをこれに移動します
はSDカードフォルダです。これは、
このSDカード
がコンピュータにマウントされたときにこのワークフローがトリガーされるため、自動的に発生
します。SDカードを接続するだけで、この
ソフトウェアが
オーディオファイルをそのフルに自動的に移動します。  SD
カードフォルダを1.5秒間一時停止
して転送が完了したことを確認してから、
見たとおりに開き
、5秒間一時停止
して、確認して完了したことを確認して
から、コンピュータを確認します。
コマンドWキーストロークを入力して
ウィンドウを閉じるので
、SDカードを通常どおりに接続するだけで
、キーボードマエストロ
が残りの処理を行い、
ソフトウェアをFinalCutProにインポートする準備をします。
Final Cut Proに関して
は、いくつかの異なるテンプレートを
使用しているので、コミックテンプレートを使用しています。
音声テンプレートを使用し
ています。Yahooで行う作業用のテンプレートを使用し
ていますが、コピーします。 ノル 今
すぐデスクトップにマルコメディテンプレートがある
ので、コマンドCコマンドV
を開きます。通常
、私が長年
行ってきたことは、手動で行うことです。つまり、私は
ここでのイントロは、テキストを変更するだけです。
フッテージをここにドロップすると、
ここでタイトルを変更できます。
エンディングクレジットを準備でき
たので、通常は手動でコマンドを実行します。
インポートメニューを表示
し、これを選択してから
このインポートをすべて押す
と、ここに表示され、
両方のオプション
コマンドGを選択してメディアを同期し、[
OK]を押します。 私もこれらすべてを処理
するワークフローを作成したので、今はそれを行い
ません。すべてをキャンセルして
、Final
CutProがこのフッテージをインポート
しないようにします。すべてが正しいことを確認します。 さて、私が
行っていることは今行ってもいいです
これを閉じると、前に見たテンプレートのコピーが削除
されます。Alfredを起動し、Alfredを使用して
、このワークフローを実行するスクリプトを実行します。
編集用のテンプレートを準備します。
ホットキーまたは
キーボードマエストロから直接名前でスクリプトを使用します
が、私はアルフレッドを好むので、今は
そのトピックに入る
つもりはありません。PTを実行するだけです。PTを押すと、
これがトリガーされ、編集用のデフォルトテンプレートが準備されます。
コンピューターはたくさんのことが
起こるので
、プロセス全体を非常にすばやくナレーション
しようとします。Enterキーを押してOKを押して、
コンピューターが
デスクトップのフォントのテンプレートのコピーをコピーします。 本当に
速く、Final Cut
Proが開きます。インポートメニューが開きます。
これらの2つのファイルをビデオにインポートし、
それらを同期し
て、同期されたファイル同期を呼び出します。
その後、30秒ほど待機します。
アウディ o
ビデオ
サンプル
ビデオを使用しているビデオの長さは1分ですが、通常、
私が使用しているビデオは約1時間、
場合によっては1時間、 半分な
ので少し時間がかかることがあるので
、デフォルトとして30秒を指定しました。これにより
、コンピューターは必要に応じて考えて作業を進めることができます。また
、ファイルをタイムラインにドロップします。
何かを押すと、そのファイルの先頭に移動し
ます。
ここに波形
が表示されます。このファイルのオーディオに移動して下にスクロールする
と、コンプレッサーが表示されます。 エフェクトオーディオエフェクト
が適用されているため、オーディオの
見栄えやサウンドが良くなり、ビデオ全体で
オーディオを手動でダックダックする必要がなくなりました。
これは、II
が今やっていることです。 するつもりです
私たちはスキップするつもりです
私が日本語で話していた場所を少し見
てみましょう。今すぐそこに行きましょう。
ここに行きましょう。ここに行きます。ここに行きます。
スペースを切り取って別のカット
を入れます。音声
フォームでわかります。 これを切り取ることができます
それから私は
すぐそこに別のカットをするつもりです大丈夫大丈夫おっと申し訳ありません私は
すぐそこに別のカットを入れるつもり
です これ
は、すぐに何かクールなこと
をするつもりです。それを切り取って大丈夫です。
これは、多かれ少なかれプロジェクト
のようになるので
、地元のエコノミストファイルにメールを送ります。
ここから始めて、
すみません。
色をすばやく適用して、
それぞれがどのように見えるかを確認しましょ
う。今は通常はマウスでこれを行っていますが、色
は現在適用されています。 これは
、
私がすべての種類のデッドスペースを切り取った後のプロジェクトの通常の外観
です。  enカットなので
、見た目も感じも非常に似ているカットがたくさんあり
ます。それらのカットから最適なカットを選択
しますが、議論のために
、これがプロジェクトの最終的な方法であり、
これらの5つの
クリップがここにあります。 字幕を追加する必要
があります。これを最初からコピーして、
そこに貼り付け
てから最後まで拡張し、
キーボードショートカットを使用してすばやく切り取ることができます
が、最近アルゴリズムを作成しました。 または、
タイトルを追加するためのマクロでも
あるので、このマクロの機能は
オプションsを押します。
カーソル位置に標準タイトルを挿入します。これ
により、オプションSをもう一度押すと
、キーボードレイアウトが次のように設定されます。
このキーストロークを入力します。1秒間一時停止
し
ます。標準のヒットを入力します。
ここに表示されている他のすべて
の操作を実行します。マウスを特定の位置に移動して
クリックすると、すべての操作が実行されます。 この
ようなものなので、私たちが行うときに何が起こるかを正確に見てみましょう
これを
もう一度行う必要があるのは、オプションSを押すことだけです。
そのオプションsを試して
みましょう。
ここで標準で入力されたこのメニュー
が開き、
ここでマウスをクリックしてからQを押します。
タイムラインにドロップしてから、この
ウィンドウを再び閉じ
ます。タイトルのデフォルトの
クリップリンクが非常に長いため、クリップが適切な長さに短縮され
、クリップの末尾
もアクティブになり、
簡単に作成できるようになりました。
このクリップの終わりであるか、このクリップの終わりであるか、
またはそれが何であれ、私が必要とした長さは何であれ
、明らかにこれは時間の節約になり
ます。私と同様のワークフローをいくつか見てみましょう。
ふりがなのレッスンのために書いたので、ふりがなの場合
もよく
似たようなこと
をしますが、ふりがなのレッスンで使用するグラフィックは、常に
大きな大きなグラフィックを使用します。
マンド
PまたはオプションPはかなり似たようなこと
が起こるので、オプションPを見てみましょう。
他
のタイトルと非常に似ていますが、
カスタムタイトルを作成したタイトルは、
大きくならないように作成しました。 繰り返しに
なりますが、音声学のレッスンでは常に大きいタイトルを使用している
ため、これらは
キーボードで作成したワークフローマクロの一種であり、実際に
スピードアップするのに役立ちました。
当然のことながら
、このタイトルのこのテキストをここで変更する必要があり
ます。申し訳ありませんが、
キーボード
ショートカットを使用して、コマンド4を押す
と、ここでフォーカスが検査官に表示されます。
タブ1、2、3、4を押す
と、
入力を開始できるので、テストテストテストと言うことができます。
もう一度コマンド4を押してから、タブを4
回押すと、
キーボードマエストロにそれを実行させることが
できます。 プログラミング前 ssコマンド
4、次にタブ4回ですが、最も速い
ことがわかったので実際に行ったこと
は、テキスト選択がどこにあるかという
ことです。これは非常に単純な
マクロであり、パワーを実際に示していると思います。
キーボード
マエストロの、そしてそれ
は私がこのプログラムが何をすることができるかを私が言おうとしていることを理解するのは簡単です
この
ホットキーオプションを押すと、それはマウスを動かし、
この位置でそれをクリックするので、この位置にあるものは
うまくいきましょう これ
は私のマウスが
動いているのを見る位置です。1082と54を下にすると、
ここがこの場所に
なります。そこに行ってFinal Cut
Proに移動すると、テキストインスペクターのボタンが正確に表示さ
れます。 最初の
キーボードマエストロがそれを実行し、
その直後に
テキストボックスに少し下がっ
てトリプルクリックします。これ
は、テキストフィールド内をトリプルクリック
すると、必要ではなくすべてのテキストが選択さ
れるためです。 コマンド4を実行してから
タブタブタブタブ次に入力を開始
するオプションTを実行すると、
すぐに入力できるようになるので
、これはテストしてからコマンドであるともう一度言うことができ
ます。タイムラインスペースに戻ってきました。
次のタイトルまたは次のタイトルの上にカーソルを合わせると、
コマンドTをもう一度実行
し、ここに戻ってテストテストテストを
実行します。このソフトウェアで実行できることは
本当に無限な
ので、音声学でいつも行うこともあります。
レッスンは、これ
が多くの人にとっておそらく不要な情報である場合は申し訳あり
ませんが、これも
本当に私を助けてくれたので、これが
少なくとも一部の皆さんに役立つことができれば、
私は本当に
あなたにその情報を提供したいので、1つのこと
音声学のレッスンでよく行うこと
は、テキストの一部
を他のテキストほど不透明ではないテキストにすることです。その
ため、不透明度を少し下げます。たとえば
、これから見てみましょう。
パニックという言葉を書いて、日本の名前
は、
100％の不透明度ではなく、100％の不透明度ではなく、不透明では
ないはずです。以前は
、このように選択
してから、ここで下にスクロールしてフェイスメニューを表示します。
不透明度ボタンを3-0と入力し、
Enterキーを押します。それで、上
にスクロールして
必要な操作を実行し
ますが、タイムラインなどに戻る可能性があります。
20レッスン全体で30回、私は
時々それが本当に苦痛だと知っていることをします、
そしてしばしば私は
これらの他のメニューにいて、ここに行き
、それから私はこのメニューに行く必要が
あります 時間がかかり
ます。このように拡張しない限り、スクロールして到達
する必要がある
ため、このコンピューターで拡張する必要があります。私がすべて
を処理するマクロを作成したかっただけ
です。 これを試してみましょ
う。同じ
テキストをもう一度選択しますが、次に進みましょう。 キーボード
マエストロとワークフローを
すばやく確認するため、選択したテキストの不透明度を
30％に設定して、FinalCutProでのみFinalCutPro内でコマンド3を押すと
、マウス
を必要な位置に移動してスクロールします。 マウスを
下に向けてクリックすると、
そのメニューが不透明になり、顔のメニューが不透明になります。
次に、メニューが移動し、
もう一度少し下にスクロールして、
一時停止する番号を直接クリックします。
30と入力し、
Enterキーを押すと、そのボックスから移動
し、最初にロールバックして、
そのテキストボックスに戻ったので、
私がしなければならないすべてのことをもう一度見てみましょう。 コマンド3を押す
と、すべてが実行されるので、
今すぐコマンド3を試してみましょう。コマンド3を
間違えた可能性が
あり、すべてを
100％に戻したいので、これから実行します。  select
all textをコマンドしてから、この
ワークフローを実行します。setselectは不透明度
を100％に検出するので、それはjusです。
前のワークフローと同じですが、
30ではなく100なので、コマンド1を実行するだけで
戻ってきて、設定し
た3つの数値の50％100％と30％を簡単に切り替えることができる
ので、これはキーボード
マエストロです。
特定の編集ワークフロー内でそのプログラムを使用する方法
です。これは、私が持っているワークフローの1つだけです。
これは
、私の視聴者の多くが、私の
ような日本に住んで働いている可能性があると思うからです。
自分のミニ
ビジネスをやっている人が、いわば定期的に行っていることの1つ
は、自分の費用を
スプレッドシートに入力して、日本円で何かを買うと、それを米ドルに換算する
ことです。 日付
を入力してからアイテムの名前を入力したので
、これは貸借対照表ですが、
これは実際の貸借対照表のコピーであり、
間違った番号がたくさんあり
、そのままです。 同じアイテムが
何度も繰り返されたので、コンピューター
カメラマイクソフトウェアサウンドパネル
コンピューターマイクと私はこれを行いました。
明らかに
、YouTubeで実際のバランスシートを共有できない
ためですが、これは私たちの仕事には役立つはずです。
何かを購入するたびにそうしようとしているので
、外部グラフィックカードを購入するつもりだとしましょう。外部
グラフィックカード
と言うことができる
ので、これを手動で入力しました。これ
をグラフィックカードのミニに入力し
ます。 カードを失礼します。
今日は
6月12日です。
それから、日本円で購入しまし
た。たまたま
約500ドルのハワイアンだったとしましょう。しかし、
それが実際に何であるかを理解する必要があります。
税金をIRSに報告するときに
、その正確な金額を差し引くことができる
ので、それを帳消しにするのは費用
なので、以前は
その金額をコピーしてから、この
Webサイトにアクセスして通貨コンバーター
を作成しました。 ここに貼り付けますc これに同意し
てから、このドキュメントに戻って貼り
付けて、これらのすべての手順を個別に貼り付けてください。そうしないと、すべての作業にかかったすべてのことを実行
するのはそれほど
大したことではないこと
がわかります。 スプレッドシートで作業するのは
、基本的に世界の何よりも好きだっただけ
です。多くの人も
そうかもしれないと感じているので、これ
を自動化するワークフローを作成したかった
ので、
皆さんのためにワークフローをデモンストレーションします。
これを保存して閉じ
ます。このワークフローが行うことは
、Alfredでワークフローをトリガーすることです。これはすぐに
表示され、次のようになります。
そのファイルを開くと
、金額が日本円で入力
され、Alfredワークフローを使用してUSDに自動的に変換され、
変数を使用して今日の日付を入力します。
その後、私がしなければならないのは書き留めるだけです。
アイテムの名前な
ので、最初に削除しましょうこの
外部を削除します ファイルからグラフィックスカード
を取得し、これが機能するかどうかを確認します。
通常、アルフレッドを再度呼び出します。キーボードショートカットを使用してこれを行います
が、円の費用
は、この特定の
ワークフローで使用するトリガーまたはキーワードです。 誰か
がyeと入力して、Nの経費
額を入力するので、v Beaumont 50,000
ですが、Enterキーを押すだけで
、コンピュータが残りのすべてを処理するものには触れません。
これを試して、Alfredを開きます。 そしてそれは
すべてを入れたので私が今する必要があるのはあなたがした
EGPだけですそれで
何が起こったのかを正確に見るためにもう一度それをし
ましょう私が買ったとし
ましょう私は私の電話の充電器を知らないので同じことをします
アルフレッド・インの費用
と私の電話の充電器を呼び出すものは私が5000円を知らないということでし
たファイルを開くためにENTERを押すと
マウスが何も押されないような良い場所に移動します
それを切り替える5番目の5000を入れることができ
ますか したがって、USDは今日の日付を入力し
て、アイテムの名前に移動します。
アイテムの名前の列に移動
します。必要なのは、電話
の充電を行うことだけです。これ
で、この種の別の例になります。
アルフレッドとキーボードマエストロの組み合わせを使用して作成したワークフローマクロの
このソフトウェアは、
ワークフロー
と5
分3分10分1
分かかるものと少しかかるこれらすべてのさまざまなタスクを必要とする完全なゲーム
チェンジャーでした 時間の経過とともに
数秒になります。
以前にZhuJieの動きについて話
しました。彼は、キーボードショートカットを学ぶときに
、これはマクロにも当てはまると思います。これは
、
節約できる時間の秒数ではありません。
手動で行う必要がないため
、
これらのさまざまな費用を投入したり、以前のよう
にFinal Cut Proでマウスを動かし
たり、プロをセットアップしたりするのにそれほど時間はかかりません。
SDカードまたはオーディオファイルをSDKに移動するか、移動しますが
、
心配する必要がない場合は、
これらすべての小さな
タスクを1日中実行するストレスがないため、これが非常に
役立ちます。 そしてそれは私が
本当にする必要があることに集中することを可能にします
それは創造的な仕事の執筆であり、
キーボードマエストロは私が今まで出会っ
た他のどのソフトウェアよりもそれをすること
を可能にしまし
た MacまたはWindowsのオートホット
キー。
このソフトウェアがどのように機能するかを少し学ぶだけで
、コンピュータの使い方を完全に変えることができるからです。
ちなみに、MacSparkyという名前の
人が最近4時間をリリースしたと思います。
キーボードマエストロを効果的に使用する方法についてのコース
そのコースからすべてを学ぶことができる
ように、これを使用する方法を学ぶことに興味がある場合は、
そうすることを強くお勧めします。ここでビデオを終了します。ありがとうございました
。
よろしくお願いします。またすぐにお話しします。
さようなら